اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
الظاهريه جنوب الخليل بالضفه الغربيه
واطلق جنود الاحتلال الرصاص الحي وقنابل
الغاز السام المثيل للدموع من خلا في خلال
مواجهات مع فلسطينيين وصدرت مركبات واغلقت
عرض من المحال
التجاريه من مخيم طولكرم ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره ليث جعار ليث نتعرف معك اذا على
اخر تطورات هذا التوغل الاسرائيلي تبعنا
معك في الساعه
الماضيه دخول اليات الاحتلال الى
[موسيقى]
المخيم نعم تتواصل العمليه العسكريه في
مخيم طول كرم وفي هذه الاثناء وقبل لحظات
فقط توجهت جرافه من طراز دي 9 برفقه
جرافتين دواليب وايضا عره اليات عسكريه من
مخيم طولكرم باتجاه مخيم نور شمس في هذه
اللحظات
لربما من الممكن ان تكون قد بدات ايضا
عمليه عسكريه لجيش الاحتلال بالتزامن مع
مخيم طول كرم في مخيم نور شمس بعد توجه
هذه الاليات العسكريه باتجاه المخيم هنا
في مخيم طول كرم لا تزال او لا يزال
الاحتلال
يحاصر المخيم بشكل كامل هنا نرصد في هذه
الصوره في هذه اللحظات حاله تهجير ايه
بدات بالفعل لجيش الاحتلال من او
للمواطنين من قبل جيش الاحتلال في هذه
اللحظات هنا نرصد عوائل خرجت من داخل
المخيم بعد على ما يبدو يعني اقتحام
منازلهم والاعتداء على الاطفال الاعتداء
على الساكنين والنساء محاوله ترويع
الاطفال متواصله في مدينه وفي مخيم طول
الكرم في هذه اللحظات بدا بالفعل بعض
العوائل يعني تخرج الى لربما قصرا من داخل
هذا المخيم بعد اقتحام متواصل لجيش
الاحتلال وا نفذ خلالها حمله مداهمات
لعشرات المنازل عشرات المعتقلين
ويعني منذ ساعات الامس الحاله في داخل
مخيم نور شمس كما تحدث بعض المواطنين يرثى
لها بسبب او نتيجه
ل يعني الاعتداء والحصار الذي يطبقه
الاحتلال والخناق الذي يطبقه الاحتلال على
مخيم طول كرم اذا بالفعل بدات اولى ال
الوفود للمهجرين لربما من داخل مخيم نور
شمس من النسائي والاطفال في هذه او مخيم
طول كرم عفوا في هذه اللحظات من النسائي
والاطفال تخرج الى من داخل المخيم باتجاه
الشارع الرئيسي بالتزامن مع استمرار
العمليه العسكريه وتواجد لجيش الاحتلال
الذي يعني اقتحم عشرات المنازل ينفذ حملات
مداهمات واعتداءات واسعه في هذه اللحظات
في كافه ارجاء المخيم هنا العوائل الاطفال
بداوا بالخروج في بعد يعني تهجيرهم لربما
من داخل هذا المخيم هنا تشاهدون الحصار
الذي يطبقه الاحتلال بشكل كامل على كل شيء
هنا في المخيم يمنع الدخول او الخروج الى
المخيم لساعات او منع ساعات طويله هذا
الامر ادى لربما الى نفاذ لربما الطعام
والحليب لضى الاطفال فبالتالي لجات
العائله الى التهجير القصري من داخل
المخيم لاعانه انفسهم واطفالهم نتيجه لهذا
التشريد وهذا يعني الاعتداء
والهمجيه التي ينفذها الاحتلال بحسب ما
يتحدث هنا الفلسطينيون قوات الاحتلال تطبق
الخناق على كافه مداخل المؤديه الى مخيم
طول كرم بالتزامن مع بدء او استمرار
للعمليه العسكريه التي طالت ما يزيد عن
يعني 100 منزل على الاقل داخل هذا المخيم
منذ ساعات فجر امس وحتى هذه اللحظه نتحدث
عن اعتداء جديد واقتحام جديد لمخيم نور
شمس بالتزامن مع هذه العمليه العسكريه
وحاله التهجير التي يشهدها اليوم مخيم طول
كرم بالتزامن مع استمرار العمليات
العسكريه في شمال الضفه الغربيه او من
شمال الضفه الغربيه الى جنوبها نتحدث حتى
هذه اللحظه اربعه شهداء استهداف لمركبه
اسعاف وطواقم الهلال الاحمر الامر الذي
ادى
لاصابه اثنين من هذا الطاقم نتيجه
لاستهدافهم بطائره مسيره ايضا معاريف
اعلنت بشكل رسمي عن استهداف واص اصابت احد
الجنود في داخل مخيم نور شمس وفي عمليه في
مخيم نور شمس باصابه خطيره الامر الذي
لربما ادى الى دفع بالتعزيز العسكريه
الجديده الى مخيمي طول كرم ونور شمس ل
استمرار هذه العمليه العسكريه واستمرار
الاعتداءات المتواصله بحق الفلسطينيين ما
يزيد عن 100 معتقل حتى هذه اللحظه على
الاقل وصلوا الى مراكز التحقيق اليات
الاحتلال العسكريه تعمل على نقل هؤلاء
المعتقلين من داخل المخيم الى مركز
التحقيق الذي اعده الاحتلال في منطقه شارع
السكه الى الشمال من مدينه الطول الكر
شكرا جزيلا لك من طولكرم ليث جعار مراسل
الجزيره